President Trump is reinforcing his legal
team in the wake of new attacks on the
special counsel leading the Russia
investigation the president hired a
lawyer who's pushed a controversial
theory about the Justice Department's
role in the investigation but the White
House maintains the president has no
plans to fire Special Counsel Robert
Muller chip Reid is at the White House
chip good morning well good morning the
president has found a kindred spirit in
his newest lawyer Joe digenova is a
former US Attorney for Washington DC
he's been a frequent guest on Fox News
where he's been outspoken about FBI
plots to aid Hillary Clinton he's also
called Special Counsel Robert Muller and
his Russia investigation an
embarrassment and yesterday just hours
before the White House announced his
hiring digenova attacked FBI director
Chris ray for remaining silent about the
recent firing of deputy director Andrew
McCabe where is the director of the FBI
isn't it amazing he's like it's like
he's on a milk carton somewhere in the
Washington Metropolitan Area Chris Ray
has become an embarrassment to the FBI
about the FBI director it tells you he's
a coward ray who has maintained a
neutral tone as FBI director was
appointed by President Trump himself but
now with the president taking a more
aggressive posture against the special
counsel he's surrounding himself with
people like like digenova who are not
afraid to go on the attack against
Robert Muller Gail all right thank you
very much chip Reid